[Music]
[Applause]
all right let's bring in chris bannock
sports illustrated senior writer
uh he was uh at game four celtics nets
last night covered the entire serie
entire series and he joins us now chris
what's your take away from what you saw
in this series
uh
on the celtics side
they're as good as
any team left playing in the nba you
kind of knew that coming into this
series because of the way they've
dominated defensively the best team in
the nba by a country mile you know since
january 1st by a lot of metric
well you also go they were what 23 and
24 at one point and then they went on a
run yeah the turnaround has been
remarkable we can get into that but i'm
just
like the way they defended kevin durant
was the best i've ever seen kevin durant
defended in the series like and there
are mitigating factors for durant steve
nash
how he let him kevin durant just hang
out there for 46 minutes in game three
and 47 minutes in game four i mean dan
how bad must cam thomas be
that you can't play him for five minutes
while durant is exhausted durant missed
that free throw
at the end of the fourth quarter that
would have given the nets a chance and
look the guy doesn't miss a lot of free
throws you had to wonder in the moment
was it because he was so tired from
playing all those minutes but give the
celtics credit their defense
was excellent whether it's jayson tatum
jaylen brown grant williams who's
emerging in this playoffs as a terrific
defender um they are as good as it gets
defensively in the nba and that defense
is transferable you can play that
defense on anybody across the league
since january 8th including the sweep of
the nets the celtics 37 and 10. if
you're going to point one finger of
blame
in the next direction
which direction
uh
kyrie for starting all this i mean
you know kyrie's spoken a couple of
times during the series about chemistry
issues and the inability to develop
cohesion with the team
well whose fault is that like you know
this team wasn't able to get him on the
court for more than half
in the first three quarters of the
season that played a factor in all this
and outside of game one and some decent
minutes in the fourth quarter of game
four
kyrie didn't just show up i mean i had
people within the boston organization
that were talking about how it's eerily
reminiscent to how he played in that
first round or second round series
against milwaukee a couple of years ago
where they just seemed checked out
of the series so i mean there's a lot of
blame to go around but i mean kyrie has
to absorb the bulk of it both for what
he did during the season that prevented
them from developing that chemistry to
how he played outside of game one of the
series
do you think the nets are going to give
him max deal
i don't know what choice they have you
know
the nets would prefer not to obviously
but
is there some team out there that would
is there like i'm just making this up
because they always do crazy things but
like would sacramento uh out there you
know give him a max level deal and they
would lose him for nothing the nets
don't have
a lot of moves here dan i mean kevin
durant is locked up joe harris is locked
up coming back ben simmons he's got
three years left in his contract that is
untradeable at this point you let kyrie
walk it's not like you clear this max
level cap space to go out and get
somebody else it's kyrie
or it's nothing at this point and as
dangerous as it is
to give him a four-year contract or a
five-year contract even in the
neighborhood of 200 plus million dollars
what else are you going to do they made
their deal with the devil so to speak
and and this is kind of what this team
is going to look like moving forward
ben simmons and his agent reportedly had
a meeting with the nets yesterday
like
why would you have a meeting on the day
of may you know an elimination game
potential elimination game
about your playing status or future or
what
what the hell is going on
well i think they had to
dan because
there was disappointment within the nets
organization that ben simmons wasn't
going to be available
for game four i mean everything that
seen leading up to sunday was that ben
simmons was getting there he came out
and spoke late in the week about how he
was feeling better how he had no
concerns about jumping back into the
fray steve nash said on saturday that he
had a great three on three came out of
it uh feeling fine and then sunday
morning comes along and he's got this
back issue and he's not ready to play so
i think they had to address it head on
with brooklyn because there was
definitely some disappointment
reverberating uh through your
organization i was honestly a little bit
taken aback dan
that
even though he wasn't playing
he wasn't there on the bench he wasn't
supporting his team in elimination game
at the barclays center now you know the
nets officially said it was because of
his back but i mean come on like sitting
on the bench you know for a couple of
hours in what could be the last game of
the season is really going to impact
your back i got to believe and this is
more speculation than anything else that
there was some anxiety within simmons
team about fans turning on him him
sitting there on the bench in his
very
multi-colored outfits and and drawing
the the ire of fans uh that were seated
in the nearby sections
i just don't understand the organization
they should have had one voice and that
one voice was going to say he's not
playing unless there's something
miraculous that's happening he's not
going to play so let's just take the
topic off the table and then he comes
out and goes i can't play in game three
but i could play in game four well
he's doing this to him this is
self-inflicted as well but the nets did
this as well
how the hell do you get a herniated disc
in your back if you haven't played all
he hadn't played at all in a year
it's it's an indictment
of
not what ben simmons did once he got to
brooklyn but of what he didn't do while
he was in philadelphia when he was with
the 76ers even though he wasn't playing
he had access to everything that they
had to offer there he could have gone
into the facility every single day
worked with the coaching staff work with
the medical staff worked with the
training staff at the very least made
sure his body was in tip-top shape now
the back injury
it predates this season i mean you go
back to 2020 when he had to sit out at
the end of the pre-pandemic season he
was dealing with some back problems but
if you haven't played since last june
and you know you're not going to play
for philadelphia that season for
whatever reason you have an obligation
to make sure you're as physically
healthy
to be in that kind of condition and
dealing with that type of issue is
really inexcusable
uh
i'm watching james harden i i just don't
get what happened to james harden and
then he took 11 shots last night he
knows that joel embiid is hurt i i have
to have him take 25 shots
yeah
yeah right
i just don't
you know
last year
when
james harden got hurt
you know
when he
struggled a bit
down the stretch you attributed to the
hamstring you said all right he's got a
hamstring issue young 32-33 he'll be
okay but
he doesn't have the burst he once had
then like he
when he was at his best in houston he
got you on his hip he went by you he got
to the free-throw line i think we've
been so focused with james harden about
how the referees have changed how they
call the game he's not getting the same
foul calls that's the issue i don't
think that's it i mean i've watched a
lot of james harden over the years he's
not getting to the rim in the same ways
he used to get to the rim and
look he's had multiple hamstring
injuries over the course of his uh
recent career
is it ever going to come back you know
you talked about kyrie and the dangers
of getting him
an extension i mean james harden's made
it clear like he's gonna be looking for
that 270 something million dollar
five-year contract when this is over
that
that is going to be an albatross around
the next of the 76ers for years to come
think about where this team would be if
tyrese maxey wasn't playing out of his
mind early in this series so uh you know
these next couple of games
they're a referendum on james harden you
know
joel embiid that thumb's not going to
get any better we know that that's a
torn ligament in his thumb he's going to
play through it i give him credit for
that but this is where james harden has
to step up and make plays or this sixers
team they absolutely could become the
first team to go out after going up 3-0
talk to you chris as always we'll check
back in with you during the postseason
thank you
you got it dad that's chris mannix
sports illustrated senior writer